Great. You're listening to radio man,
the podcast from New York public radio public radio, w.
Y. C. N. N. P. R. Hey,
I'm Jad Abumrad and I'm Robert Krulwich gcs radio lab pod cast. Yes.
Cool. That was exciting. And this particular turn of our wheel,
we are going to be taking up a very odd, odd idea, which is,
um, is it possible for a human, a man or a woman? Probably a mature man.
A woman. We'd hope to build their own universe. Yeah.
Do you mean like in theory? No, actually this, I'm going to,
this is a serious proposition.
There are people who are now thinking about it seriously at Stanford, in Israel,
in Japan,
a theoretical physicist who are trying to figure out how one might go about
this. Go about building a universe,
a whole universe as in like a carpenter, like an a carpenter,
Correale sort of way. Like, here build a table, carpenter oriel sort of way.
So you know where that's not possible, right?
Because the universe is that which we are apart of.
So how can you build something that is that we are already a part of that gang
sense. To begin this conversation, we do have to consider this word universe,
which to most of us, as you just said, means everything that is everything.
And therefore by definition it should only be one of them. Yes, of course.
But for physicists like Brian Green, our friend Brian Green,
who came to my kitchen so we could have this discussion,
two physicists like him,
he's very comfortable with the idea of more than one universe,
and that's been the case for physicists for a while. Now,
I don't know the first time,
but the idea that there might be many universes has surprisingly cropped up in a
variety of different contexts. In physics, for example,
Brian Seth see expansion of space.
The blossoming of a universe that we have called the big bang was not a single
event,
but it's an event that happens over and over and over again and distant and
far-flung regions of our universe, other universe sprout out,
have their own new big bangs giving rise to a kind of cosmic bubble bath of
little bubble universes of which our universe is simply one.
And then this idea of universe is or multi versus a natural word to use to
describe the collection of all these bubbles,
each of which if it hasn't happened,
it's like us would think that that is thug universe,
but now you see it's only one of many and this was something that somebody
thought up in 92019301950 well,
the inflationary theory itself was developed in the early 1980s and this
recognition that it could give rise to this many universes was developed by a
number of incredibly creative physicists in the mid eighties into the 90s and
it's still studied today, so it's kind of a new idea.
Then this version of it is new.
No explorer has ever ventured into one of these other universities is the best,
you know? Right. This is simply a mental,
this is a conclusion of a mental process,
not of a Columbus or Magellan kind of process. That's true.
We are confined to our bubble and we really can't get out and explore the other
bubbles. So from that point of view, it is a mental exercise,
but a powerful one.
But you can see how hard it is for somebody who doesn't read the world through
mathematics,
but just reads it to his senses or her senses that this explanation seems
nonsensical since you've no sensual experience of another universe.
The only one you've got is staring at it at equations.
That's true.
But I'd say that the history of physics of the last century has taught us to
strenuously challenge
our perceptions strenuously challenge. The things that intuitively seem obvious.
We have learned that the Adam is made up of particles that can be both wavelike
or particle like that. In some sense, it can be two places at once.
None of us have experienced any of those things.
None of those things feel right according to our intuition.
But I assure you the experiments that have been done over the last 80 years have
confirmed each of those crazy ideas over and over and over again.
So I don't think it's a good guide to use our senses and our intuition to
determine what we think is right or wrong.
We have really have to follow the laws of physics and see where they take us.
Okay. You with me here, Chad? I am, yes. All right,
so let's say really? Yeah, no, no, no. I'm here. Really?
Where am I going to be? I'm here to here. All right,
so let's say that you can have just in principle anyway, more than one universe.
Okay? Now the question is how do you go about building one? Yeah,
that's what I want to know. You said at the beginning,
we can build them ourselves, right? So this is not, you know,
anything like a act of magic or a godlike thing.
This is just as far as Brian is concerned, this is a practical,
I'll be kind of crazy. A practical engineering problem.
So then how would you engineer one? Right? Let's get to our main subject.
Well that's what I asked Brian. The question.
The proposition here is not only can you have more than one of them,
but that you,
you and ordinary human being and some pals can make make
one.
Is it conceivable to you that there could be something called a manmade
universe?
People have studied this and nobody's really been able to say that it's
impossible and some have even suggested hypothetical ways that you might
actually do it. Well, let me,
I mean the first question I'm gonna ask is how one,
are there several ways to do this? One Way to do this? How many,
how many different paths? Well,
I would say at the moment there's no one way that anybody has been convinced is
really compatible with everything that we know.
There are a number of suggested ways,
but they all rely upon more or less the same physics and that physics has to do
with a strange feature of gravity that none of us have ever experienced.
But the math shows us is true and observations of space seem to confirm.
And that is the gravity can actually be not only attractive,
it can only pull things together. It can also be repulsive.
It can push things apart. If that were the case,
then wouldn't we all be combusted? Well,
the repulsive side of gravity only rears its head in very special environments
and everyday life. The earth,
the solar system and so forth are realms in which it doesn't rear.
It's repulsive side strongly enough to have any effect.
But we have learned that on the largest of scales, even in our universe,
we believe that gravity is exerting its repulsive side,
which is what's causing distant galaxies to be rushing away from us at an ever
accelerated rate. They're rushing away faster and faster. So the repulsive side,
there's actually direct observational support for what does that have to do with
creating a universe. However, because it seems to me that creating a university,
you'd want to somehow manage the thing and repulsive center,
particularly if it's a fierce repulsive force,
which seemed to make it be a kind of a unmanageable situation. Well,
if you want a manageable way of building a universe,
what you want to be able to do is build something pretty small.
But it's small things, not a universe. So it has to expand, right?
For something to expand. There's gotta be some outward push,
there's gotta be some repulsive push.
And that's where this repulsive side of gravity comes into the story.
So I want to build something that is a seed of another universe,
but inside my seed there has to be latently.
And then later actively some expensive thing.
Something that just wants to grow. Yes.
Now is there such a device of such as c?
There are conditions which according to the laws of general relativity,
the laws that Einstein wrote down a long time ago, well tested.
Those laws tell us that in this context of the right energy density carried by
the right substance, you will have repulsive gravity,
which means if you can build this little seed,
this little nugget in just the right way, it will on its own,
roughly speaking,
start to expand, grow faster and faster and faster,
beginning tiny and sprouting into a gigantic unit.
So I can have you see an expanding universe that is born in my kitchen and I
don't have to worry about my issue. You're having a lot of fun here,
but you've left me behind a bit. What is the seed thing anyways?
The exact nature of the seed thing is, it's actually quite complicated,
but just to give, it's a shape for you.
The first thing I learned is that in order to start a university,
any university, even our own universe, the seed has to be very, very sure.
You can calculate that the nugget that we perhaps gave rise to our universe,
maybe someone created it in their apartment, in some other universe,
was about roughly 10 to the minus 26 centimeters across 10 to the minus 26
enemy. That's small. That's really, really, really small. Yeah. Yeah.
And it wouldn't happen. It could grow into a, you know, there was,
there's enough, um, push inside it,
repulsive force or push out to then they could grow into a thing like we would
associate with universe, universe scales, our universe,
according to this theory. Again, you know,
I'm being facetious that it was created in somebody else's apartment,
but who knows. But the seed of our universe,
we believe from our calculations and our observations was roughly 10 to the
minus 26 10 to minus 27 centimeters across wade. You know, a few pounds,
about 10 pounds.
You wouldn't really think intuitively that you could build a whole universe from
10 pounds of stuff. I think you would think that to build a whole universe,
I'm talking about a universe of stars and galaxies,
hundreds of billions of stars in hundreds of billions of galaxies.
You think you need more than 10 pounds of this stuff?
But it turns out that that's all you need because the repulsive side of gravity
is so powerful that it actually injects energy from gravity itself into the
expanding space. So from that point of view,
all you need is the seed and then gravity takes over and does the rest of the
work.
[inaudible]
okay. Jet So that we now know the seat has to be smaller.
The second thing that Brian told me is the seed should come in the form of what
he described as a, as a black hole. The seed as a black hole.
[inaudible] wait a second.
You said that it has to be small, but black holes are huge,
but it turns out that black holes can be, they don't have to be big. No,
not at all. Relative. What can you get? I mean, I thought that the,
we we use or we can get the black holes cause the star collapses.
So it's a fairly gigantic beginning and therefore it's a fairly gigantic thing.
Could you get a black hole the size of a wine cup or a a thimble or less?
Oh yeah, absolutely.
You give me any object and if I squeeze it sufficiently small,
then according to the classical laws or general relativity,
if you make it small enough, it will be a tiny black hole.
Now wait a grape. Can you make, can you make a grape into a black hole?
Absolutely. Can you make a raspberry and tobacco?
Can you make a blueberry into black hole? Seriously,
there's nothing that you could give me that I couldn't turn into a black hole by
squeezing it sufficiently small.
Would there be any example of a naturally occurring small black hole? Sure.
There are processes where particles can slam into each other at a very high
energies, and the calculations show that if they slammed together,
it's sufficiently high energies in the right geometrical configuration,
they can create a tiny black hole. And this is not just hypothetical,
a new machine to Geneva, Switzerland right now called the large Hadron collider.
And one of the things that may happen at the large Hadron collider is the
creation of microscopic black holes in the collision between protons and
protons. These will be tiny black holes, but black holes nonetheless.
Wow. It is getting kind of interesting. So okay, you've got a black hole. Yeah.
A tiny one. And you've,
which we've somehow have to impregnate with this anti gravity force. Yeah.
Uh, what other ingredients do we need? Now we need a trigger,
something to trigger in the expense of force on. So it'll go,
what's the trigger? Well, the trigger is a very, very complex.
Frankly,
I only kind of 80% got the trigger and I don't want to bore you with it,
but it is,
it's something about a compass with only one needle or something like that.
But anyway, once you, once your benefit don't ask,
but once you've got the trigger,
which you add to the a little black hole and now you've got the expensive force
line that you pull the trigger and you will get a universe of your own right
there in your kitchen. But doesn't that worry you? I mean,
wouldn't that blow up everything?
It just seems that if you create one, you would be, um, you would be in danger.
People have studied that issue in great detail and found that at least according
to the proposals that are on the table for how in principle you might create a
universe that wouldn't be a worry that wouldn't happen. Instead,
this universe that you create would in essence create its own space.
It wouldn't encroach on your space by expanding into your domain,
into your house, into your region. Instead,
it would expand like our universe does.
But it would expand by creating new space space that hadn't existed before.
So it would be off on its own if you will, creating a new bubble,
a new bubble universe that would be a universe in its own right.
So what do we see
from our side? What would we see? Probably,
I'm not sure cause Brian is with me during this particular conversation,
but I think Brian would say what you always see is our little black hole on our
side and something, something we, you know,
going on very large on the other side,
it's staying little on our side but getting bigger on the other side and can we
jump through it? Well that's the interesting,
you know,
you need to jump in to be able to see what's going on on the other side.
So if you were, if you could make one of these, you might be able to inspect it.
You'd be at a certain cost, you couldn't, you couldn't come back,
you couldn't pass through. Um, but you're,
what you're creating on the other side is there.
And in principle you could go there. So
if you could make your own universe, um, you would never,
ever,
ever be able to come back to visit anyone or anything you ever have known.
Could you ever imagine having made a creation on this scale?
Could you ever imagine visiting it forever and never going back home?
Never. Well, no radio, no, no radio on us.
You know how many people would be sad?
Someone is just a small little sliver of humanity. They'd get over it.
If you could actually do this beyond theory, I'm going to have to say,
I think I might have a little trouble resisting this possibility just because
it's so curious.
This idea that through your volitional act,
in your kitchen sink,
you are creating a universe that would give rise petard perhaps to things like
we see in the world around us. Really,
you can think of our universe potentially as being the outcome of the
hypothetical processes that we're talking about, our universe,
speaking of which we should say,
our universe or our corner of it is funded by the Sloan Foundation of the
corporation for public broadcasting and the National Science Foundation. Also,
thank you to Brian Green, who is professor of, let's see,
physics and mathematics at Columbia University in New York is also the author of
the elegant universe and the fabric of the cosmos.
One day he may create himself a little bit of cosmos.
Is this probably plausible to you? It's very tough to say.
I do consider this speculation on speculation,
so I think I would stress that the reason for thinking about this is not so much
to do it, but it's more to push the laws of physics to their breaking point,
because that's often where we learn new things about how the world works.
Until next time, yes, two weeks, we'll see you then. Bye.
[inaudible].